train we're gonna have to eat you what
you said more than podcast was so funny
about the apocalypse that homeless
people are going to be psyched because
waiting for the end of the world because
they know what they're doing they know
the spots and [ __ ] exactly the good is
not gonna change might get better we'll
see you get crown dudes in favelas if
you live in the favela you don't have to
worry about the end of the world because
it's already the end of the world for
you you know you already mastered you
don't most people that are walking
around pushing shopping carts with all
those plastic bags hanging off them
they're probably most likely mentally
ill batshit crazy we're all probably
okay ultra throw aways problem child
trafficking to be some of them have to
be some throw away because we all know
trafficking is going on and like what
happens to these people you know a lot
of them are veterans that's where it
gets real